[Musik]
virtueller parteitag der csu wegen
corona treffen sich die delegierten nur
im internet auch inhaltlich geht es um
die bewältigung der krise mehr corona
tests mehr sicherheit
gesundheitsminister sparen will ein
vorsorgliches screening in
krankenhäusern und pflegeheimen und
flugzeugunglück in pakistan eine
passagiermaschine stürzt in ein
wohngebiet viele menschen sterben
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
barbara hahlweg guten abend und
willkommen zum nachrichtenüberblick an
diesem freitag schön dass sie dabei sind
die csu steht gut da im moment ihre
umfragewerte sind in der krone krise
kräftig gestiegen
ihr chef ist bundesweit beliebt wie nie
auf platz zwei hinter der kanzlerin
jetzt will die csu mit einem virtuellen
parteitag die weichen für die zukunft
stellen
und das heißt die für die partei nicht
ohne ende geld für hilfsprogramme
ausgeben die csu plädiert für eine
obergrenze bei der staatsverschuldung
will aber trotzdem steuern senken und
den konsum ankurbeln zum beispiel mit
einer autokauf prämie
außerdem will die csu den 5g ausbau für
schnelles mobiles internet massiv
beschleunigen aus münchen berichtet
alexander pohl als hätte man sich auf
eine computerspiel messe oder in einen
hacker club verirrt die parteitagsregie
der csu derweil vor der tür
masken auf der parteichef kommt kein zug
kein tamtam von seinem büro spricht
markus söder zu 250 delegierten
zugeschaltet aus ganz bayern
seine botschaft bei allen notwendigen
milliarden ausgaben müsse die csu die
stimme der ökonomischen vernunft sein
wir dürfen nicht diejenigen sein die
eine spirale nach oben entwickeln und
jeden tag neue vorschläge machen wie man
hunderte von milliarden zusätzlich
ausgeben kann
das muss ein programm sein wenn man noch
mal was drauf macht das dann maximal bis
100 milliarden geht eher weniger eine
schuldenobergrenze maximal 100
milliarden euro soll der bund zur
bekämpfung der korona krise zusätzlich
aufnehmen dürfen einerseits andererseits
fordert bayern steuererleichterungen für
unternehmen und kaufanreize für neue
autos auch das kostet milliarden
wir müssen die finanzmittel effizient
einsetzt setzen das ist das
entscheidende
also alleine ist er machtlos wir müssen
es technologieführer bleiben wir müssen
an der weltmarktspitze bleiben wenn wir
unseren wohlstand erhalten wollen
zugeschaltet aus wien der
österreichische bundeskanzler sebastian
kurz wie markus söder warnt auch er die
bekämpfung der korona krise dürfe nicht
zu einer vergemeinschaftung der schulden
in europa führen
der heutige virtuelle csu-parteitag er
gilt auch der vorbereitung für den
nächsten koalitionsgipfel im juni
dort soll über den weiteren weg aus der
korona krise beraten werden soll man in
münchen die csu will der wirtschaft
kräftig impulse geben aber nicht so viel
geld ausgeben ist es kein widerspruch
das ist natürlich ein widerspruch und
die bayerische staatsregierung hat ja
auch bisher auf sehr umfangreiche
konjunkturprogramm gesetzt will das auch
ausdrücklich in zukunft weiter tun das
wird alles sehr viel geld kosten
dass sie trotzdem diese obergrenze für
schulden in den leitantrag aufgenommen
hatte ich glaube das lag daran dass die
parteiführung die stimmung an der
parteibasis wahrgenommen hat da entsteht
ein druck viele csu mitglieder fragen
sich was wie viele schulden kann ein
staat aushalten und was bedeutet das für
die junge generation
ob nun ein so kurzer parteitag von
gerade mal drei stunden geeignet ist
solche komplexen fragen zu klären
das bleibt allerdings dahingestellt die
einschätzung von unserem münchner
korrespondenten jürgen bollmann vielen
dank im gegensatz zur csu halten die
sogenannten wirtschaftsweisen eine
kaufprämie zur unterstützung der
autoindustrie für keine gute idee
die regierung dürfe dem druck einzelner
branchen nicht nachgeben heißt es in
einem beitrag des sachverständigenrats
für die süddeutsche zeitung
besser wäre es die energiekosten zu
senken oder in bildung und infrastruktur
zu investieren
der blick auf die aktuellen corona daten
für deutschland zeigt die zahl der
täglichen neuinfektionen ist leicht
gestiegen
so kommen im durchschnitt der
vergangenen sieben tage derzeit täglich
650 ansteckungen hinzu
stand 18 30 hat die johns hopkins
universität seit ausbruch der pandemie
gut 179.000 infizierte registriert davon
gelten mehr als 159.000 als genesen 8200
19 menschen sind in verbindung mit 19
gestorben
um die ausbreitung des virus zu stoppen
sind vielmehr tests nötig viele wissen
ja gar nicht ob sie das virus haben oder
nicht die kapazitäten sind da der
politische wille auch die frage ist nur
wer das ganze bezahlt wer im moment
überhaupt getestet wird und was es
kostet zeigt florian coaching empfohlen
und bezahlt werden die korona tests
immer wenn sie medizinisch notwendig
sind dazu zählt wer akute symptome
aufweist oder kontakt zu einer
infizierten person hatte auch wer im
krankenhaus in eine station mit
risikopatienten aufgenommen werden soll
wird getestet ebenso diejenigen die in
einem alten oder pflegeheim wohnen oder
arbeiten noch allerdings nur dann wenn
es ein arzt für nötig hält
getestet wird auch in bestimmten
branchen wie etwa der fußball bundesliga
hier werden die kosten aber nicht von
den kassen übernommen sich ohne
konkreten verdacht testen zu lassen wird
zwar nicht empfohlen ist aber möglich
wer darauf besteht muss allerdings
selbst zahlen kostenpunkt circa 150 euro
vergangene woche wurden gut 400 25.000
tests bundesweit durchgeführt mehr als
eine million wären möglich gewesen also
mehr als doppelt so viele
gesundheitsminister sparen will jetzt
schnell patienten und personal in
pflegeheimen und krankenhäusern tests
ermöglichen auf kosten der krankenkassen
die aber wehren sich tests von
symptomfreien menschen gehörten nicht zu
ihren aufgaben
einige bundesländer wollen diesen streit
nicht abwarten sie zahlen die
flächendeckenden test selbst wenn glas
berichtet aus baden württemberg
ein rachenabstrich um zu sehen ob diese
pflege heimbewohnerinnen eningen mit dem
corona virus infiziert ist im gesamten
landkreis reutlingen haben sie
inzwischen alle bewohner und mitarbeiter
der pflegeheime vorsorglich getestet
ergebnis ist dass von den bewohnern die
wir getestet haben und die kubi 19
infiziert sind drei viertel über 73
prozent nicht gewusst haben dass die
kogit 19 infiziert haben die haben keine
symptome
eine gefahren da auch symptomfreie
patienten die erkrankung weiter
verbreiten können
deshalb werden in baden württemberg
derzeit alle pflegeheim bewohner und
mitarbeiter einmal komplett durch
getestet bezahlt vom land
wir brauchen gerade jetzt einen klaren
stand über die infektions lage um die
entsprechenden schutz und
quarantänemaßnahmen treffen zu können
damit wir nicht wieder infektionsketten
erhalten wie baden-württemberg will nun
auch der bundesgesundheitsminister mehr
tests die ankündigung sieht folgendes
vor
krankenkassen sollen tests von
kontaktpersonen eines infizierten auch
dann bezahlen wenn diese kontaktpersonen
keine symptome zeigen
außerdem sollen corona tests zur regel
werden bei neuaufnahmen im pflegeheim
oder krankenhäusern und in pflegeheimen
und krankenhäusern soll auch vorbeugend
mehr getestet werden der minister
spricht von präventiven reihen tests
eine gute richtung und es bestimmt eine
wertvolle strategien es macht mir schon
sorgen dass wir quasi test kapazitäten
haben die wir nicht ganz ausnutzen
insofern glaube ich auch dass so eine
strategie schon vor hätte da sein können
in einigen jedenfalls war das
umfangreiche testen erfolgreich sie
haben erkrankte vorübergehend isoliert
momentan ist die einrichtung corona frei
nach china ins ursprungsland des virus
die wirtschaft ist dort eingebrochen das
verhältnis zu den usa weiter schwierig
beim volkskongress liegen drängende
themen auf dem tisch rund 2900
abgeordnete wollen die jetzt angehen elf
wochen später als geplant ohne abstand
aber mit mundschutz nur die
kommunistische führungsriege um
präsident sie will keinen und verkündet
neben wirtschafts helfen eine
hiobsbotschaft
peking kritische bürger in hongkong aus
peking und freuler nervös sind sie in
der hauptstadt selbst harmlose
interviews nach dem leben in der korona
zeit gelten als verdächtig wir werden
von der polizei gestoppt
zeigen sie bitte ihren ausweis fordern
sie wir bekommen drehverbot obwohl es
ein öffentlicher platz ist vor der
anreise mussten alle delegierten ein
corona test machen jetzt gedenkt der
volkskongress mit einer schweigeminute
den corona opfern
china will seine wirtschaftskrise mit
einem staatlichen konjunkturprogramm
bekämpfen
tschechiens hunderte millionen
profitierten von politischen maßnahmen
so premierminister li keqiang die preise
stabilisierten und die produktion
fördern präsident china starker mann
weiß um die wirtschaftskrise vor allem
der konflikt mit den usa droht zu
eskalieren
aus peking kommen moderate signale beton
tot wie die china werde mit den usa
zusammenarbeiten um das handelsabkommen
auszusetzen
harte töne dagegen richtung hongkong
china will ein sicherheitsgesetz für die
sonderzone verabschieden
deshalb gingen wenige hongkonger bürger
heute spontan auf die straße sie
fürchten dass ihre freiheitsrechte
drastig eingestellt werden
der rechtsstaat ist dann geschichte wenn
das gesetz kommt china lässt die muskeln
spielen präsident will die korona krise
hinter sich lassen und freunde in peking
vor was genau haben die menschen in rom
kommen angst sie haben schlicht gesagt
einfach angst dass man die verbliebene
freiheit die sie noch haben ihn nimmt
china hat dies schon mal versucht damals
hat das hongkonger parlament ein
sicherheitsgesetz gestoppt es gab keine
mehrheit nun macht china peking das
einfach selbst lässt das hongkonger
parlament außen vor und sagt dann wenn
das gesetz verabschiedet ist dass die
hongkonger regierung die peking treu ist
das eben umsetzt in hongkong hat das
doch für einen großen schock gesorgt man
will am samstag versuchen eine
großdemonstration hinzukriegen
aber man muss auch ganz klar sagen dass
die demonstrations- und protestbewegung
doch deutlich an kraft verloren hat bei
dem letzten protestwellen insgesamt im
letzten jahr sind 8000 menschen
festgenommen worden
insofern fehlt die kraft also das fazit
ist ein sehr schwieriger tag für die
demokratiebewegung in hongkong
dankeschön zur neuesten aktion des
us-präsidenten dass donald trump ein
weiteres internationales abkommen
kündigen will hat weltweit viel kritik
ausgelöst
es geht um den so genannten open skies
vertrag der die abrüstung zwischen ost
und west absichern sollte mit hilfe von
beobachtungsflügen um militärische
aktivitäten zu kontrollieren
david sauer hat die details ein offener
himmel von vancouver bis wladiwostok
diese idee ist das fundament des open
skies vertrags er wurde 1992 zwischen
nato-staaten und ehemaligen mitgliedern
des warschauer pakts geschlossen und er
erlaubt gemeinsame aufklärungsflüge im
luftraum der anderen
das heißt zb amerikanische maschinen
dürfen mit hochauflösenden kameras
russischen militärstützpunkte
fotografieren und umgekehrt
35 länder haben den vertrag
unterzeichnet auch deutschland nach ende
des kalten krieges sollte so vertrauen
aufgebaut und transparenz bei der
rüstungskontrolle geschaffen werden
eine form der legalisierten spionage um
kriege zu verhindern
für staaten mit modernen
überwachungssatelliten haben die flüge
inzwischen an bedeutung verloren
james argument russland habe
beobachtungsflügen etwa über die
militärisch wichtige region kaliningrad
eingeschränkt den vertrag also verletzt
auch die nato partner sehen da durchaus
ein problem das sei aber kein grund
gleich den vertrag zu kündigen sagt
außenminister maß aus brüssel berichtet
uniklinik es geht genau um solche flüge
eine russische maschine am himmel über
washington im august 2017 die soldaten
an bord fotografieren gebäude und
militäreinrichtungen des open skies
abkommen erlaubt dass donald trump aber
vermutet spionage und will aus dem
vertrag in sechs monaten aussteigen
russland hat sich nicht daran gehalten
so lange sie das nicht machen
ziehen wir uns daraus zurück
funktioniert hat das abkommen aus sicht
der europäer ziemlich gut seit 2002
machen sich militärs ein bild des
anderen
die fotos werden gemeinsam aufgenommen
an alle 34 vertragsstaaten verschickt
zuletzt aber verhinderte russland
überflüge über die russische exklave
kaliningrad die usa reagierten ebenfalls
mit einschränkungen
das russische außenministerium nennt die
kündigung eine weitere etappe der
demontage der internationalen sicherheit
es ist vielmehr so dass es von
russischer seite konkrete und klar
formulierte vorbehalte gegenüber den
amerikanern gibt was die verträge
anbetracht das abkommen aber wolle
russland weiter einhalten
in brüssel kommen die nato-botschafter
zu einer sondersitzung zusammen fast
alle nato länder beteiligen sich an open
skies sie bedauernd rams rückzug und
appellieren an russland einzulenken
wir sind uns einig dass alle
vertragsstaaten von open skies ihre
verpflichtung und vollständig erfüllen
müssen
alle nato alliierten heißen sich an
diese vertragsbestimmungen unterstützung
für trumps kurs habe es bei der nato
allerdings nicht gegeben der himmel über
europa ist an diesem tag nicht sicherer
geworden
ein schweres unglück erschüttert
pakistan ein passagierflugzeug zur
stellte in einem wohngebiet an bord
waren etwa 100 menschen die viele
todesopfer es gibt es noch unklar
der airbus stürzte wenige minuten vor
der landung ab das flugzeug war auf dem
weg von der stadt lahore im osten
pakistans ins südlich gelegene karachi
anja fröhlich schwarze rauchwolken heute
mittag über karachi im süden pakistans
aus der nähe zeigt sich die verwüstung
trümmer flugzeugteile und leichen
verteilt in den engen straßen des dicht
besiedelten wohngebiet model kolonie
gegen 12 uhr 12 meldet der pilot per
funk technische probleme die triebwerke
sind ausgefallen
wenige sekunden später stürzt die
maschine ab der airbus a320 geht in
flammen auf
99 menschen sollen an bord gewesen sein
darunter acht besatzungsmitglieder
wir haben einen lauten knall gehört es
hörte sich an wie ein erdbeben
wir dachten eine wand sei eingestürzt
als wir aufs dach kletterten sahen wir
nur noch raus wie viele menschen hier
unter den trümmern begraben sind ist
unklar
bislang konnten rettungskräfte 34
leichen werden bewohner helfen mit nach
überlebenden zu suchen
angehörige suchen trost am späten
nachmittag dann in all dem chaos eine
gute nachricht
drei passagiere sollen das unglück
überlebt haben
in indien und bangladesch hat zyklon am
fahren schwere schäden hinterlassen
mindestens 95 menschen kamen ums leben
an vielen orten haben jetzt die
aufräumarbeiten begonnen weite
landstriche an der küste sind
überschwemmt zehntausende häuser
zerstört indiens ministerpräsident modi
besichtigte die schäden bei helikopter
und kündigte hilfen von umgerechnet rund
120 millionen euro an
noch mal zurück zu corona in südamerika
steigen die infektionszahlen rasant in
brasilien aber auch in chile und das
virus sorgt zunehmend für soziale
spannungen in chile protestieren
verzweifelte menschen die ihre arbeit
verloren haben gegen die ausgangssperren
christoph reckert berichtet fernanda
kauft ein nicht mit ihrem geld sie hat
keins mehr
sie kaufte ein für andere für jene die
aufgrund von corona nicht mehr in die
supermärkte gehen wollen füreinander ist
schauspielerinnen studierte übersetzerin
wegen der krise kann sie beide berufe
nicht ausüben und muss schauen wie sie
über die runden kommt es ist eine
riskante arbeit bei der arbeit benutze
ich eine doppelte maske und eine
schutzbrille und handschuhe
meistens zumindest jetzt gerade habe ich
keine handschuhe weil ich kein geld
hatte welche zu kaufen
füreinander und hier freuten asio haben
einen sohn kassius musiker und gibt
jetzt online unterricht doch auf dauer
so leben können sie nicht denn fast zwei
drittel ihres einkommens sind
weggebrochen
wie so viele gehen haben sie angst vor
der zukunft eine angst die sich immer
öfter in wut und gewalt entlädt schon im
letzten jahr waren die menschen auf die
straße gegangen um gegen soziale
ungerechtigkeit und armut zu
protestieren
jetzt flammt diese wut wieder auf weil
die quarantänemaßnahmen die not vieler
verschärfen
die angst vor dem tod der verwandten
durch corona von menschen die einem nahe
stehen die angst vor dem eigenen tod ist
der angst vor dem hunger und der
unsicherheit gewichen
die regierung sucht nach antworten
präsident pinera hat ein umfassendes
hilfsprogramm angekündigt zunächst
sollen zweieinhalb millionen der ärmsten
familien mit lebensmitteln versorgt
werden
doch mittelschichtler wie für einander
gehen bislang leer aus und das virus
breitet sich immer weiter aus
auch in chile steigt die zahl der
infizierten und der opfer stark an
zum sport spielen oder nicht spielen in
der dritten fußball-liga ist darüber ein
heftiger streit entbrannt denn der dfb
hat festgelegt die saison geht weiter ab
die meisten vereine sind auch dafür im
osten regt sich aber widerstand einige
klubs fühlen sich benachteiligt weil in
ihren bundesländern noch corona
beschränkungen zu den sportstätten
michael spindler
der dfb hat ein machtwort gesprochen
dass gewaltigen zündstoff in sich birgt
der neustart der dritten liga am 30 mai
ist für einige vereine wie carl zeiss
jena oder den halleschen fc in
organisatorischer und sportlicher sicht
eine zumutung
wir kennen den dfb das interessierte
nicht das mögen wir jetzt was die
vorbereitung auf die letzten spiele
anbetrifft dass wir nicht so weit sind
im training wie andere mannschaften das
eben und das ist den anscheinend egal
hauptsache die saison jetzt zu ende
gespielt bereits am wochenende müssen
alle drittligisten ihr siebentägiges
quarantäne trainingslager beginnen
obwohl die politik in einigen bundes
ländern noch gar kein
mannschaftstraining erlaubt nicht mal
heimspiele im eigenen stadion sind
garantiert falls die behörden nicht
mitspielen sollen die vereine sich
selbst um ein ausweichstadion kümmern
argumente die der dfb aber nicht gelten
lässt sehen sie wir sind in einer
ausnahmesituation wie ich erwähnt habe
und wir wollen um diese
ausnahmesituation sportliche
entscheidung herbeiführen und
sicherstellen
und wir müssen auf diesem wege
kompromisse alle miteinander eingehen
bis zum 14 juli soll in fünf englischen
wochen die saison durchgezogen werden
allerdings könnte das letzte wort noch
nicht gesprochen sein denn in jena und
halle prüft man nun juristische schritte
und wir schauen noch wie die britischen
royals versuchen die stimmung in corona
zeiten hoch zu halten
in gebührendem abstand natürlich suchten
william und kate vom heimischen
wohnzimmer aus den spielerischen kontakt
zu den bewohnern eines altenheims in
wales das prinzenpaar zog die
glückszahlen mit den royals war sehr gut
sagt siegerin so hätte aber noch ein
bisschen besser sein kann
das wetter könnte auch ein bisschen
besser sein schauer gewitter und
dauerregen sind angesagt mehr hat gleich
essent herrlich für sie christian simons
begrüßt sie um 10 im heute journal
wir danken sehr für ihr interesse und
wünschen ihnen ein schönes wochenende
was machen wenn sie auf wiedersehen
[Musik]
einschränkend und herzlich willkommen
zum wetter endlich bekommen wir wieder
neuen regen mit einer kaltfront und die
bringt vor allem in der nacht im osten
den regen und auch nach süden hin
ja und im westen lockert es schon wieder
auf die temperaturen sinken dabei auf 9
grad ganz im norden und 17 grad im
südwesten deutschlands
morgen am vormittag ist es zunächst
trocken im norden aber dann ziehen
schauer und gewitter auf und breiten
sich nach osten aus dabei gibt es vor
allem an der nordsee stürmischen wind
und zum nachmittag lockert sie schon
wieder auf im süden da gibt es viele
wolken und der regen staut sich hier in
den alpen teilweise gibt es auch
gewitter und stürmische böen
temperaturen dazu erreichen höchstwerte
von 16 grad in schleswig holstein und 23
grad am alpenrand
die nächsten tage gibt es noch schauer
und gewitter zum beispiel am sonntag im
norden dazu stürmischer wind an der
nordsee bis 21 grad und dann wird es
allmählich wärmer dienstag bis 25 grad
ein schöner abend